welcome to the webinar
ask us anything we're so excited to be
here today for this
all of us um today we have professors
bob sutton and huggy raoul
and as we move through the session over
the next hour if you're enjoying the
insights and you'd like to learn more
you can check out both bob and huggies
courses
within the certificate they have been
linked directly in your dashboard so you
can kind of play around with that and
find it
and we're going to jump right in today
so if you
would like to learn more about huggy and
bob's backgrounds or anything about
talisha
you will find all those resources linked
in your dashboard i'm not going to go
for the lengthy introduction
without further ado bob and huggy it's
always a pleasure
take us away
thank you so very much robin um
bob and i are of course delighted to be
here
with our audience today and we're all
the more gratified to be here because
we have our thousandth graduate talisha
garrett
uh yeah one of the things that
bob and i thought was we might actually
begin by
you know having a short conversation
with talisha
um and then opening it up for
the ask me any question uh question
format
so talisha thank you for being so
generous
in sharing your time with us
congratulations
on being a thousandth uh graduate
so what i said you know what i wanted to
sort of ask you was
how would you sort of describe getting
to this
uh you know the arc of your career so to
speak getting to this stage
are there milestones are there stages
that stand out for you
thank you javian thank you all for
having me here
um there are certainly milestones that
have
i would say have been anchors or pillars
to
get where i am today and when i think
about milestones you know i think about
those moments that are really
transformational that really help me
grow and go deeper
um and i can't help but think of a
couple that stand out
the most one is this was the moment that
i
learned that my success
will never climb higher than my
character
and i learned this moment early in my
career
thank god i was fresh out of undergrad i
had gotten a really cool position on a
pretty cool company
i was a junior financial analyst and i
was living the dream i mean i thought i
had it made i had arrived
i was there was a team of like seven or
eight of us
we were all uh young ambitious we were
single you know so we could work 18 hour
days there was no we were it was just we
were all in
and it was fantastic and um i started
getting
acknowledged for what i the value that i
brought to the table and the skills and
abilities that i had
and um you know i was getting promoted
and recognized pretty quickly
and then there came a moment after a
couple years where it just kind of hit a
plateau and i was still delivering
i was still performing um but i wasn't
getting promoted anymore
and i started to get really bitter about
it
and i started to feel very entitled
and very um just
arrogant really thinking that you know
i'm i'm
here i am i'm giving it all and and why
aren't they promoting like why don't
they see me
um and uh out of pure bitterness
i left the team i was on and
took a lateral move because i thought
you know a new team is going to make all
the difference
you know i just need to be in a
different place and they'll see my value
and
and and i'll keep getting promoted and
my career will just skyrocket
and um about three to four months after
i left the team they promoted someone
who i onboarded and trained to lead that
department
and i was devastated i was convinced
that this person stole my job
i was convinced that it was personal i
was convinced that they were
out to get me and that um you know this
this wasn't fair
um and after a lot of reflection
and talking to mentors and coaches you
know i learned that
i wasn't getting promoted because my
attitude was
really poor and i had really developed
and like i said earlier an arrogance of
entitlement
um because i thought that my skills were
all i needed and i put everything i had
into developing my
skills um but i missed
you know there was a saying that you
know you you left dead bodies in the
path and and i didn't realize that
and so i was so focused on um
getting the job done getting the job
done right that i it went to my head and
i didn't realize how much damage i was
creating
um and that was the moment where i
realized wow
okay my skill will only get me so far
but my character and how i interact
other people
is what will sustain me and i took about
two or three years and really started
doing a lot of inner work thinking about
who do i want to be and who like almost
like an identity crisis
of who am i you know i had spent so much
time
um being who i thought i was supposed to
be
and focusing on the skills i thought i
was supposed to have
in focusing on the next job the next
title the next
upward mo you know movement and um
once i realized that it was so much
deeper than that
i started becoming a lot less impressed
with
titles and positions and you know
salaries and i was more impressed with
like
the inner person of tell me what's
behind the title in the position
and really help me understand um
understand you as a person and once that
lens shifted for me
um and i don't think it was a
coincidence but that's when my career
really started to take off of when the
lens of focusing on
building a solid foundation took place
that was probably one of the biggest
lessons i've learned
as far as in my professional life
was that my skill set will only get me
so far
thank you for that beautifully
it's an account characterized i would
say
with searing honesty and self-reflection
thank you here's the way i heard you and
i wanted to run it by you
and the way i heard it was the big aha
for you was
hey i need to move from skill to self
yes um
the real thing in life is not choosing
one job or another
or being promoted to one job or another
but really what matters is which version
of yourself
are you choosing a reasonable way to say
what you said
absolutely absolutely and i think for me
at the
time i was so confused about
myself i had so much you know i grew up
pretty um i mean visually you can see
i'm a black woman i'm biracial my
grandmother is
caucasian my mother is um is mixed
and so i grew up in this space of
not really being clear on which version
of myself was acceptable
and not really being clear on
on who i was and what was important um
and always feeling this sense of just
being othered uh
feeling like you know there was there
was a box that i just for the life of me
could not fit into
and so when i when i entered the
corporate space
in my mind that was my opportunity to
fit inside the box
that was my opportunity to you know what
if anything else i'm going to be the
best performer here
i'm going to outshine anyone i can i'm
going to be in this box of what
corporate success
is defined or at least what i thought it
was defined as
and you know that didn't work that
didn't work
and so through that that phase of
self-reflection i realized you know
fitting in the box may not be the goal
right maybe the goal is not to fit in
the box
what if this otherness that i had felt
all of this time is really my superpower
what if i can embrace that and start to
rather than reject
the pieces of myself that i felt were
other
what if i can start to embrace that and
leverage that
um and learn more and gain the
confidence
in being able to show up and being
others okay and that really
settled for me when i had my daughter
because
uh you know we live in a predominantly
caucasian area and
she's brown skinned and so when she
started asking questions about
her otherness it really started to
highlight in me
the areas of my otherness that was
important to embrace
um and and again you know how do we take
this
what feels like um something we should
change and
embrace it as something we can we can
really accentuate
that's a very beautifully put uh
talisha and you know the way i sort of
heard it was in phase one
your emphasis was on hey conformity
and assimilation is sort of what matters
and then phase two actually is no
it's actually it's me being
[Music]
me getting in touch with my best self
for who i
am i'm curious as i
as i listen to you and then imagine many
in the audience are obviously listening
very intently
might you actually sort of share with us
this tension between
being an exception and being exceptional
you know in the eyes of other people
and do we have to be exceptional in the
sense of
getting in touch with our exceptional
self or is it the other way around
i think we become exceptional by getting
in touch with our best self
but i think sometimes we
only get the drive to become exceptional
when we realize we're not really the
exception
if that makes me
so i think that um you know
for a long time um i was the exception
you know my mom
had me at 16 years old so all the odds
about
what success looked like and what kind
of environment you needed to breed
success
were against me um you know i grew up in
a
relatively poor community um there were
no silver spoons in sight um
you know i i um once i started i
i had this drive early on to know that i
i wanted to go to college i knew i
wanted to go to college but no one else
had done it
um my uncle graduated college and he was
the first to do it
um and so there was just a lot of
exception just in my upbringing of you
beat the odds you beat the odds and so
that exception is what bread in me this
idea of
i am um i thought that my
it's i i thought that um the exception
was like i had hit the lottery or
something like
it was this luck of the draw where you
know
it's it's just me it's just me and this
is just how i am and
lucky me uh and it wasn't until i
started to um go through the cycles of
learning like oh
man i really need to focus on my inner
self like i can't
some of these outer things are not going
to sustain me
um and i started embracing all the
things that
made me the exception and looking at
those from a reflective
place and saying you know what there are
some really good skills and abilities
that i do have
and that's okay and yes there are a lot
of areas where i may be the exception
for some
but there are some exceptional qualities
that i have and that i can embrace
and that i can bring to the table and so
although
yes there are a lot of things in my
upbringing
that were stacked against me there was
absolutely a lot of work and effort that
i put in
to ensure um that i would be exceptional
you know but i found that um
as i said a little bit ago like some of
that feeling of an exception and that
otherness
i've really been able to embrace that
and turn it into somewhat of a
superpower
of yes i am i am different and i am
i you may think i'm other compared to
your lens and that's okay
and that's okay um and in that there are
still
some amazing qualities that i've
naturally have
and that i've developed and continue to
grow in that i'm going to bring the
table as well
coming back to what you were just sort
of saying
one question i had was what did you
think of
the sign the learning
opportunity was that like a gym for you
to
help you choose a different version of
yourself
or was it merely a place where you got a
certificate in the credential or
how would you describe the courses
i mean and what happened to you that's
kind of what i'm interested in
yeah it was certainly um a gym i would
say
i you know as as i've gone through this
journey i've
i've just kind of i mean i i don't know
if i've become cynical about it but i'm
less impressed with credentials
right um so i certainly um i'm
rarely a fan of unless it's something
compliance related
i'm rarely a fan of getting a
certification for the sake of saying i
have a certification it just doesn't
make sense to me conceptually
and it's a waste of time frankly this in
the case
was such a gem in that um you know
one of the one of the strengths that i
realized i had was
this kind of going against the grain
challenging the process i'll say
um and thinking outside the box
and all those terms that we now call
innovation right
but but i didn't have a good framework
to really bring that into a corporate
space because oftentimes
innovation is looked at as
entrepreneurialship
and so one of the things that i think
the biggest lesson i've learned
and the reason why this course was a gem
for me is it really taught me about
entrepreneurship and how do i take those
entrepreneurial mindsets and apply them
into the infrastructure of a company
and how do i embrace the going against
the grain and embrace the challenge in
the process and embrace
the um asking lots of questions and
developing an innate sense of curiosity
to inspire innovation in the workplace
um you know for me i don't have a desire
to be an entrepreneur
and i used to connect entrepreneur
innovation as
one like that they go hand in hand and
they do
but i i learned from this program i can
also bring that innovative mindset
right where i'm at into the work that i
do and it's been great my
uh my directors have have certainly uh
noticed a difference and provided lots
of feedback and
embraced the ideas of let's look at this
like it's our little
it's our own inner clients what will we
do differently
you know how do we feel differently how
do we lead differently
music to certainly my ears and bob's
ears as well
so as you think about innovators or as
you
refer to them intrapreneurs within an
enterprise
so if you were to think of like a simple
equation
entrepreneurship equals two variables
um curiosity and generosity
so i'm wondering what do you think is
the relationship between curiosity and
generosity
is it diabetes is it multiplicative
for an innovator do you need to have
curiosity squared multiplied by
generosity
or curiosity multiplied by generosity
squared
and you can imagine the variations
therein what's your take on
what matters i think
curiosity and generosity are
directly correlated and i think they are
exponentially correlated i think
that um curiosity if i had to put this
in an equation
this is my language now i think that um
curiosity to the nth degree
equals the absolute value
of generosity
and i think that the more curious we are
the more we are willing to give and and
be
generous in giving and that could be
giving in time or money
but also giving it thought giving it
um giving an energy giving in support
and so i think that um whatever the
topic is the more curious we are
about that it exponentially increases
the totality of what we're willing to
give
into um addressing that curiosity
yeah oh that's beautifully put i mean
the curiosity itself is an act of giving
the act of asking the question itself is
an act of giving
right but i've often thought questions
are
gifts you know and
that's uh so
asking about questions might i ask you a
mischievous question
sure sure well what's the
um what's the toughest question you've
asked at work
for example of your boss of your team
of anybody toughest question you asked
anybody
[Music]
it the toughest question i've asked um
was i had a really contentious manager
and this was um
she was almost i mean she was not not
much short of a bully she was just
really
um authoritative and hierarchical and it
was her way or no way
if it didn't make sense and um
she had this rule and at the time i was
a relatively
new mom not her issue at all you know
the company was
um going through trying to be more
accommodating to working virtually and
being more flexible with
start and stop times and she was
adamant that every day we had to be
there at 7 00 am
regardless no if answer but you were
there seven sharp
um and and that was just the rule
because she said so
well i had a child care arrangement
where
um there was a day where you know my
the the my nanny or my sister was not
able to to get my daughter to school and
so i had to go to school
so i'm like this is non-negotiable i'm
going to be late take my daughter to
school it is what it is and we get there
and we have this she had this whole
conversation with me
about why i'm going to be there at 7 am
and why i needed to
why this was important for the team and
i looked at her and i
said demonstrate to me how me being here
at seven
adds any more value to you or the team
and she had no answer and she was
frustrated
that i questioned her authority and i
said
i we continued and i shared you know i'm
not one
for rules for the sake of power
um so if that's not going to work for
you i'm happy to engage hr
and i'd be glad to leave your team um
that was probably the most um
provocative or provoking question
it's a very powerful question to ask and
you know and as i listen to you one of
the things i
just quickly flashed across my mind was
how leadership sometimes pays attention
to voice
of employees but completely
ignores their lie i mean what's
listening to an engagement survey if i
don't understand your life that you have
to
you know organize child care and do a
bunch of things i mean
this is life right really yeah
that was that was uh that was uh
uh my god what a memorable memorable
encounter
now since we're talking about the world
at work i'm going to throw in another
mischievous question you know bob and i
like a little bit of profanity
and so let me introduce that to you and
i'm wondering
in your work life what was the biggest
cluster
you were ever part of and you know you
don't need to name
the names of products or business units
or whatever but
the biggest cluster that you were part
of
yeah um this is one that
um i was i observed i'll say i wasn't
directly a part of but observed
and at a a company i was working at
we had implemented these um
communication boards if you will and the
idea was that
you have a communication board at every
part of the manufacturing journey
for that plant and um they would have
things like quality and safety in people
and and
and whatnot and every morning at a
certain time you would walk the
leadership team
which i was a part of at the time would
walk the boards
and really try to get status on the
current state of production and
manufacturing
and so um when they went to implement
this
the ground rules were pretty simple in
that it
it needed to be um started small and
organically grown
and it needed to be led by the employees
pretty straightforward um so you can
imagine
what the leadership team did they did
the opposite
so they put boards everywhere and they
drove it
and the employees were adamant in saying
this is not the right time this is more
invasive to our space
than adding any value for us you're
actually taking away from productivity
this is not a good fit for us right now
in the leadership team
um being as hierarchical as they were
they said nope we got a mandate we gotta
go do it well they didn't get a mandate
they got a set of
framework to implement but they read
that as a mandate
and so um so every several weeks we had
a vp
um of our manufacturing the entire
division come and they'd walk the board
with us
and it was pretty systematic they came
at the same time
every few weeks so they could predict it
and
one of the weeks that they came the
employees
because they weren't getting heard had
gone on every board
and erased the row that said people
um sending the message that the people
don't matter this isn't about people
this is about you
and simultaneously at the start of the
meeting
they started blasting over the intercom
circus music
and it i mean if you could see
everyone's face when that happened it
was priceless and that was certainly
the biggest cluster
because our our
director had no clue what to do he was
so caught off guard
he had no idea what was happening and
you know we all kind of looked and said
well
they've been telling you this they've
been telling you this isn't going to
work and so that was their way to get
the message across
was to play circus music across the uh
that morning
wow what a story we've actually had a
couple of questions kind of coming in
right
yes huggy we do okay a lot of great
questions
yeah um you know
and talisha please feel free to join us
as we respond to these questions but
um before we leave are there any parting
parts
a piece of advice for our listeners
i would just say if you're here in the
program and you are
earning this certificate ensure that you
go back and apply it
i think one of the biggest um
waste that we offer is the amount of
knowledge we consume without sharing it
back
out and so i think
the more you can adopt it internalize it
make it your own
and then share it would just help
with that it's that generosity component
right the more curious you are about the
learnings you gained
in this program then you can give that
out
to where you work your families etc
because all of these concepts apply
to so much more than just work
yeah oh this is uh you know
this is actually a beautiful gift to our
audience saying hey
if you don't use it you lose it so
what's the value of your curiosity
unless you're generous
really really well put thank you for
leaving us with this thought about
thoughts about
not just your experiences all of which
were riveting
but this idea that the innovation
mindset
is this beautiful multiplication of
curiosity and generosity
let's all join in giving talisha a warm
thank you and our gratitude
and congratulations thank you thank you
thank you
so much bob is giving it some value
tries he may get on he may not
but what we do have right now is we have
many awesome
questions that have come in okay can you
quickly curate them there because i'm
looking at the chat option can you
quickly read them out
the way i can first question up huggy
can you think of your top few tips to be
a better leader
someone is asking you what are they if
you could help someone out with that
this is a really good uh question who's
asking the question i'd like to
recognize the
person asking the question too you know
i'm so sorry honey i'm working for you
okay once you ever ask the question
thank you so much
yes the most important thing about
really leaders to my mind are recruiters
you can't do anything on your own if
you're a leader how are you going to do
anything on your own unless you recruit
people
so the most important thing to
understand is that as a leader
your fundamental task is to be a
recruiter you've got to get people to do
things for you
what's going to help you the most being
a hippopotamus
who constantly opens his or her mouth
and doesn't listen to other people
that's not going to help you
instead being an elephant helps you
being patient
using all of your senses to listen and
understand your environment
keenly that's actually what's going to
happen
that to me is really the essence of
leadership
i think put simply leaders
are people with a huge help muscle
it goes back to the generosity issue the
television i were just
chatting about chatting about in just a
little while ago
excellent that was anna i asked one of
my colleagues anna asked that question
anna thanks so much
so much anna for asking that question
hopefully that was of help to you
absolutely okay huggy
is there any specific pattern or format
to present
new ideas to managers if you're an
entry-level individual
how many tactics great questions
great question
let me kind of quickly speak to you
about two bodies who asked this question
again
um
yeah i i always want to recognize the
person who asked the question maybe
we'll
track them so whosoever asked the
question thank you again
let me share with you two bodies of
research
one body of research shows that if you
present a superior or for that matter
anybody
with a fully finished idea you're
implicitly asking them to
judge you and not help you
so finished idea leads to judgment
not health what kind of idea leads to
health
and roughly finished prototype of an
idea
is a better idea to elicit help from the
leader
and the audience so therefore
have rough ideas so that others can add
themselves
into the idea and actually develop it
further
so that's one body of research the other
body of research is when you present an
idea
your job is not to persuade people but
to pre-suit
that means you don't want to sell the
idea to them
instead you want them to be ready in
order to listen to the idea
so always think about persuasion
not persuasion in this case
how would you persuade somebody you
might persuade somebody by saying hey
this idea came up because
just not my effort but it was part of a
team effort
and that way when you do that you're
immediately persuading the audience
excellent and
that was a t i'm i might be
pronouncing this wrong first name a t i
t a t
sha i'm shy yeah thank you
excellent okay
how about this one also from a t shaw
how do you deal
with a constant push back to new ideas
this breaks an individual's confidence
in succeeding
or taking their thoughts to a new level
can you
can you help with this yeah that's a
good question as well
i think the most important thing is at
which stage
the key thing to understand is great
innovative organizations
are also very good at killing good ideas
from the perspective of an organization
if you have 100 dollars and 10 ideas
the easiest thing is to allocate 10
bucks to each idea
and here what we are doing is we're
starving really good ideas of resources
and we're nourishing bad ideas when they
ought to be killed
but great organizations kill good ideas
too
so they actually put money in earlier
the most important thing is when is an
idea killed
and i think that's what organizations
aren't good at doing
in fact the question kind of
reminds me of an imagery where you know
in most
organizations there's like a committee
often called a murder board or a murder
committee that kills not only the idea
but the person with the id we need to
think of less threatening ways of
killing the idea
and i don't know whether you recall this
but in the scaling of excellence course
for example
we had a case study on right solutions
where they use
market mechanisms to kill ideas so when
peer skill
ideas it's a little more acceptable when
a boss kills an
idea because a boss killing an idea also
translates
into some level of personal invalidation
as your question
i could see that too i mean it's a much
different thing you know
as an employee you internalize
everything that your manager or your
leader does or says and so
it's just a much different thing if it
comes from well the market won't bear it
you know and then
it just gets killed thank you honey
we have a question from john magnuson
who said do you have suggestions on how
to work through core
value conflicts that are emerging during
the pandemic
such as the telework option versus
office only
yeah that's a really good question
i think
the real challenge the pandemic of
course has had a huge effect on
[Music]
and the effect it has had is it's
actually induced
of many of us to think about
reinventing the firm bob and i
wrote an article for the mckinsey
quarterly some time ago
and maybe we'll make it available robin
and you know in this article what bob
and i
suggested was one way to think about
the pandemic is it's actually about
leading in uncertain times
and the imagery we used in that article
was
people are in a room called fear and if
you're in a room called
fear you're going to be risk averse and
you're likely to have ton and wish
you need to be in a room called hope
in order to imagine what is possible and
what can be done
but the the journey of getting from the
room called hope
to the room called fear requires
passageway
and one of the things that bob and i
have were arguing in that
article is what the pandemic has done
particularly with the advent of remote
work is it's actually transformed the
psychological contract
between the boss and the support
pandemic if you were a boss your
subordinate work usually in front of you
or in some
close vicinity you could physically
observe the subordinate
monitor the subordinate
and subordinates also worked with other
people in teams
now if you're a subordinate you're
actually likely to be alone
working at home um for example
uh and if you're a boss you can't see
the support
so monitoring is a problem if you're
alone commitment is a problem
so one of the things bob and i suggest
is
the passageway from the room called hope
to the room from the room called fear to
the room called hope
is what we refer to and what the
research refers to
as your best self talisha hinted at that
too
in her wonderfully reflective and honest
conversation
so what's the best self your best self
can easily be captured into three
words which are verbs or adverbs
that is actions that best describe you
and what's the nature of the
psychological contract
the employee comes to work with his or
her best self
and the boss's job is or the boss's
obligation
is how can i give you opportunities to
express your best self
because when we bring our best self to
work
rather than our tired self our fatigued
self
our angry self obviously we're highly
motivated
we don't need much monetary that's the
nature of the psychological contract
now hopefully that gives you a sense of
that's what's going to make it easier to
actually
get into this what you refer to as
navigating these
choices the other thing that bob and i
argue in the article is
when you're reinventing the company
by going fully remote or by becoming
more distributed or what have you
you also need to re-on-board your
employees
because they're not working for the same
organization anymore
so to my mind
the value conflict is less a choice
and it's more a question of getting your
best selves to come
and the best self exercise and this
psychological contract
will rapidly allow you to focus on a
group of values but a group of values
that aren't abstract words but
accessible as behaviors
that's great but hopefully that was
helpful ah
bob's here bob sutton
we can see you bob thank you for your
persistence
you're here
i know bob's looking very surprised i
just did what i do
bob that was tenacious and true grit
thank you very much
um i don't know what happened
well you're here now and we have a
question from
dongmin and and they are asking
and this is great because you guys have
so many experiences with entrepreneurs
and industry
in your opinion what are the common
attributes of successful
entrepreneurs are there any difference
of people who are successful in a
startup
versus a big enterprise environment
well i better talk given that i've been
muted for a while
so i i referred to my buddy michael
dearing who
huggy and i have been working with for
about a decade michael's funded about
200 startups uh folks might want to look
under
um harrison metal it's just him he's
sort of like a solo
guy and uh he's got some characteristics
one of them
is essentially black and white thinking
that's one
that's one of the cognitive distortions
that entrepreneurs tend to have
is it's either great or it's terrible if
you're in a more complex corporate
environment
that's probably um better they also
tend to think that there's something
special about them
not necessarily that they're better than
anyone else but they're just sort of
cursed
with this sort of this sort of
specialness and just strategically
and and then i'll defer to huggy uh
since he does a lot of work in this area
what what good entrepreneurs tend to do
is they tend to have
a more narrow problem that they solve
perfectly
and then as the company grows they'll
tend to they'll tend to expand but
they tend to be sort of like a a rifle
shot is the way our friend john lilly
would say it
so what what would you add huggy those
are some of the that's actually a great
uh
uh list of things bro by feikin jetski a
little bit behind you
um let me kind of emphasize the
similarities to complement what you
mentioned
i would think that entrepreneurs and
entrepreneurs
they're both insurgents it's just that
the constraints they face are different
if you're an entrepreneur your enemy is
outside
because you're an insurgent you're very
much like a social movement activist
what's the most important thing about
the social movement activists they have
a cause
they got no money they got no people and
that's the first job they got to get
them they got to get people first
and maybe a little bit of money in an
organization
the entrepreneur too the entrepreneur
too is an insurgent
but often the enemy is within friendly
fire is the problem
as opposed to enemy and so
the challenge in large organizations
therefore is
how do you actually protect your
entrepreneurs by insulating them from
friendly fire too early
you need criticism you need questioning
but not too early but much much
later and so
[Music]
i would say that those are the
similarities with the difference being
the con
the the constraints vary
excellent thank you both huggy this is a
uh
question about and bob as well scaling
excellence so for people who are
thinking about
you know taking some courses within the
certificate
um i don't want to say it wrong ui
you are as asking what are the major
suggestions on scaling so if you can
just
overview just a couple of scaling
suggestions both of you so you can kind
of give them a little sneak peek of what
they could get in scaling excellence
that would be great
let me go first and then bob can
join me is that okay bob sure so very
quickly
bob and i wrote this book scaling up
excellence
because we were in a very successful
executive program called customer
focused innovation
and people in the last day of the class
asked us
what does it take to scale bob gave some
answers
i gave some answers later that evening
as we were drinking wine
we were deeply dissatisfied with our own
answers and bob said what do we do
i told bob i said we're stanford
professors
bob says what the hell does that mean i
said bob all it means
is when we don't know a subject is when
we offer a course
because it will force us to wake up look
at deletion
she thinks it's hilarious
and that's what we did the first time we
offered a course we couldn't even like
it was too
we we created too hard of a problem
remember
we asked them yes we asked stanford
students to make sure everybody
buys something bicycling on the campus
was wearing a helmet
and i remember rightly one of the
discussions we have was how to grade
them and
we thought maybe we should grade them by
the number of people in each door who
wore
helmets while bicycling and the students
of course freaked out a little bit and
they said
hey what about effort and what about
this and
what about that i remember that but
anyway high level takeaways
first thing scaling is not footprint but
mindset
how you make culture accessible to
people
second scaling is not doing more of the
same
it's a reinvention bob you want to add a
couple of other things that we learned
well yeah well to um follow your
perspective that to me the two
main decisions which huggy and i they
sound easy but in real life they're
really hard i guess the three main
when to go fast wouldn't go slow uh we
did a case of uber which is quite
interesting
they just put pedal to the metal for too
many years and got into so much
organizational and technical death they
still haven't required
uh the second thing is addition versus
subtraction something that we've
followed
in in a lot of detail knowing when to
add and how to subtract
for big organizations uh i think netflix
is an interesting example
organizations that know how to subtract
have a huge advantage
and and then the last thing we call it
buddhism versus catholicism by which we
mean
is is the decision about uh what
what we insist on i'm having everything
done in the exact same way everywhere
um versus what we allow sort of local
variations so just you know as a quick
example ikea one of the reasons they
were successful
at entering into china even though they
had mostly
the same product maybe 90 overlapping
skus
was that they figured out culturally
they needed more assembly
and more delivery service than in other
markets
so that's just if i would pick this sort
of three
fast slow addition subtraction
and uh if you will customization uh
versus uh standardization those are
those are the strategic decisions we see
over and over again and if somebody
tells you that
they know the one-size-fits-all answer
for those they're lying to you
yeah so you know hopefully what you'll
sort of get out of the courses is really
a set of tools and i think as talisha
was earlier mentioning
frameworks so that you can then figure
out
what is it that you need to do how you
need to customize
excellent thank you so let's do a little
bit of a speed round here because
bob you are for the man who doesn't like
to go to meetings i know that you need
to leave for a very
important meeting within three minutes
let's just do a little speed round
so bob and huggy um can you help answer
why good ideas die bob why don't you go
first so we can make sure that you are
departing on time and then huggy can
give us his
well while good ideas die in part
because it's really hard to sell
tell good from bad ideas and then i
would just add
one that sometimes good idea should die
because if you've got
too many good ideas and you try to
develop them all all the ideas end up
bad in the end that's out of the steve
jobs playbook
so that's my start well said bob the
only thing i'd like to add is
remember that every good idea is built
on the ruins of another good idea that
died
yes it's built with the ruins
not on the ruins
those were great and i love the i love
the fast speed popcorn round
um let's try one more
what is a key trait in your and your
opinions
bob what is a key trait of a successful
leader like when you go in you're like
this person better have this thing well
i mean
first of all anybody who tells you that
they know the one key trait is
is misleading you and exaggerating so
don't believe what i'm about ready to
tell you
but if i was gonna pick one thing i
would say that the best leaders know
what it feels like to work for them
which sort of sounds like mushy empathy
but if you're a good leader and you know
what it feels like to work for you
you also forgive me for saying this can
influence
let dare i say manipulate people to do
stuff that they don't want to do so it
isn't all
sort of warm and fuzzy and kittens and
everything
that's fair huggy
um i think i have little to add i think
bob put us really well
that context matters so much
it really does um bob it looks like it's
you made a true cameo appearance today
we really appreciate your perseverance
and great i know and when you popped up
we were just as surprised as the rest of
us when you
want to get different and i apologize
for the technological struggles
but such as the modern era we live in
thank you all so much it's it's
a delight to be part of the program
we're going to stay bye bob
bye bye okay huggy i'm going to put
forward another question
for you we'll see how we do on time and
then um
we're going to pull up and ask the
audience what they want to see more of
okay
oh talisha here's something here's
something that you can chime in with
huggy as well
there you go yeah how far
have you so your intrapreneurship
efforts
within your organization so you took the
sie courses you did the certificate
and you're in boeing which is a which is
a big organization
so did you find that you were able to
apply those principles within your
department within your team
maybe within a smaller working block
someone is asking specifically about
entrepreneurship within your
role and organization yeah happy to
share so
we have had some really good successes
in this space um so i do workforce
i'll try to keep it brief but i do work
force development for the enterprise and
our team is responsible for
um reskilling upskilling essentially
developing
uh the entire workforce with the
exception of manufacturing so we do all
non-manufacturing functions and
historically at boeing they've been very
traditional in how we do learning so
it's just here's a bunch of courses
take what you want to take but there was
a lot of continuity as to if those
courses were actually adding value to
the business not the individual per se
but the business overall
and so an approach that we took was you
know let's halt open enrollment courses
and let's start looking at roles in the
skill gaps in those roles
and providing learning for those roles
to close those gaps and tie that
directly to the business
um and for about a year or so it was
really um i mean it was a major culture
shift and still is in a lot of ways but
we just were getting a lot of resistance
to approaching learning that way
and the thing that um really resonated
and this was actually touched on earlier
was
we started coming to executives with
incomplete ideas
we started coming to them and saying you
know i'm kind of sort of thinking maybe
this
what are your thoughts what would you do
where are your gaps
and what we ended up with was they kind
of
put together our picture for us and it
was their idea
and i think um so so we've seen success
in that and now we're at a place where
we're scaling across we just finished
engineering we're scaling it across
the other functions which is a big a
huge feat um
but i've learned in this entrepreneurial
space that it has to be not about me
it has to be about the idea it has to be
about the result it has to be not about
me
once it becomes about me then it doesn't
work
and we're just one minute off ending
here huggy thank you
so much for rolling with the punches as
we do we really like to
you know we really like to keep it real
and spice it up on these webinars don't
we aggie
like we do we do
and and talisha thank you thank you so
much to you just as a reminder to
everyone
we're always really just so happy to
have
everyone join in it really you know
we're on the other side of the computer
but for us it's just really nice to have
the
back and forth of the q a and just
knowing that you're all out there thank
you so much for joining and
this will be a recording that will be
sent out to everyone
um so if you want to review anything
that talisha or hughie or
bob shared then you'll have that ability
and um
thank you everyone for coming and we're
going to end the webinar now
thanks everybody thank you bye bye
everybody
thank you talisha thank you robin
you